واحد من كل ثلاثة ضحايا سكتة دماغية لا يتصل أبدًا بالرقم
9-1-1 وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض الذي يؤخر الرعاية الحرجة
بحلول الوقت الذي يتلقون فيه العلاج ، فمن
المحتمل أن يكون هناك بالفعل
تلف
كبير في أنسجة المخ بسبب
نقص إمدادات الدم
التي يمكن أن يتسبب الضرر فيها في حدوث عدد  من
المشاكل بما في ذلك الشلل
، ضعف الكلام وفقدان
الوظيفة الحركية في الوقت الحالي ، يحاول المعيار
الحالي لعلاج السكتة الدماغية
بشكل أساسي التخلص من الجلطة
التي تمنع بشكل أساسي إمداد الدماغ بالدم
في دراسة نُشرت في المجلة
العلمية تقدم باحثين في
طور مركز ويكسنر الطبي التابع لجامعة ولاية أوهايو
تقنية لإدخال
مادة وراثية في الخلايا
يقولون إن هذا قد يجعل التأخير في الرعاية
أقل ضررًا
لأنه يسمح لهم بإعادة برمجة خلايا الجلد
باستخدام الكوكتيل الخاص بنا يمكننا نوعًا من إخبار
أو تعليم هذه الخلايا لتصبح
يقول الباحث دانييل جاليغو بيريز ،
الذي تم حقنه مرة واحدة بخلايا الأوعية الدموية في الفئران التي تعرضت لجلطة دماغية ، إنهم رأوا سيج  ns من إصلاح أنسجة المخ
عندما نظرنا إلى سلوك هذه
الفئران
أيضًا واستعادت الوظيفة الحركية
بشكل كبير ، أعتقد أن الآثار المترتبة
على
البشر الذين يعالجون البشر بهذه الطريقة كبيرة
ستحتاج إلى إجراء المزيد من الأبحاث
حول كيفية عمل هذا العلاج في الفئران
قبل  تم توسيع نطاق الدراسة لتشمل
اختبار الحيوانات الأكبر حجمًا من أجل السلامة والفعالية
للصحة الدقيقة أنا ماندي جيثر